la tormenta de nieve en madrid complicó
este lunes los esfuerzos para distribuir
la vacuna a toda españa' el vuelo que se
esperaba aterrizará con las vacunas en
el aeropuerto de barajas tuvo que ser
desviado este domingo al de foronda en
la región de vitoria además alrededor de
20.000 kilómetros de carreteras en el
centro del país se vieron también
afectados por la tormenta así el
gobierno de madrid ha admitido este
lunes que hay problemas de logística
para la distribución de las dosis al
resto de españa' estamos ante
temperaturas muy bajas donde la nieve
que ha desaparecido pero que tenemos
mucha acumulada en calzada se comienza a
transformar y tenemos ya pues algunas
placas de hielo en matriz del ejército
fue desplegado para limpiar la nieve y
de las pistas del aeropuerto los
militares también han permitido el
acceso a los hospitales de la capital
con la ayuda de voluntarios por
sustentan o colaborar con toda esta
locura bueno los sanitarios llevan más
de un año día a día nosotros es un
proceso intentar colaborar como
ciudadanos
responsabilidad de todos falta liderazgo
falta de palas pero al montón de
chavales están tirando bolas y te
estarían colaborando también pero faltas
a ese liderazgo por parte de las
administraciones desde el domingo los
equipos de rescate están entregando las
vacunas a las zonas aisladas por vía
aérea pero los meteorólogos advirtieron
sobre condiciones peligrosas en los
próximos días con temperaturas de hasta
menos 10 grados celsius esta semana y la
posibilidad de que la nieve se convierta
en hielo